Newsome is so clearly copying the Bill
Clinton Playbook that he is now even
adopting Bill Clinton's Economic Policy
vis-a-vis Republicans Ronald Reagan in
particular's Economic Policy he made
this clear on Meet the Press look at
that trip and it made you think nicely
of Nixon and Reagan why just makes me
think that we've lost
I've just dumbfounded when I think about
the Republican party today and how far
they have fallen from Reagan reaganism
Reaganomics in some respects how
different the party is today I mean the
idea that you would have Republican
president that supported Endangered
Species Act the Clean Air Act and
created the EPA in Nixon the fact that
the modern environmental movement in
many respects started with Ronald Reagan
in 1989 he was out there promoting
Reagan assault weapons ban he was
defending the LGBT community he's pretty
good he's pretty good he's leaning into
being the moderate Democrat candidate